hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast Multi tissue experiments
in a scalable and automation compatible
format it is presented by Olivier Frey
PhD who leads the technology and
platforms group at in Spiro in
Switzerland I am Judy O'Rourke of lab
rats and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots lab roots is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I'd like to remind everyone this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want any time you want
during the presentation just click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box that
appears on the screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Frey I will now turn the presentation
over to him
so hello everyone thanks a lot really
for its introduction and to lab roots
giving the possibility to present some
of our latest developments that we are
currently doing in a collaborative
effort together with ETH Zurich Allan
Farrow I would like to start to just
give you a brief numbers on arrow what
you're doing so we are specialized in
producing and engineering 3d micro
tissues we're producing over 20 tissues
20,000 tissues per month of a large
variety of different cell types and we
are doing this for industrial clients so
that they can test their substances on a
3d physiological model in partnerships
or publicly funded projects and academic
partnerships etc so we have a larger
customer basis and have around 50
employees at three different sites
worldwide
so the general platform the 3d inside
platform that we are producing is in one
hand has the goal to create irrelevance
between the in vitro assay and being
able to extrapolate these data to any
level response we do that in a most
convenient way so that the customer has
the available technology and handling
and platforms so that he can fully
capitalize from the 3d cell nature that
we are providing and the whole platform
that we have spans over the whole drug
discovery process from high-throughput
technologies using 384 well plates or 96
well plates up to very complex
three-dimensional multi tissue system in
a microfluidic environment so I would
like to first start with one of the
models which is our liver micro tissues
these liver market issues actually have
complex structures which allows all
integrated biology and an intact
metabolism and has
to control activity bile acid secretion
and is responsive to inflammatory steam
line so we use actually this really
tissue model in a recent study so we
assessed it together with AstraZeneca
genetic to test its utility for clinical
drug induced liver injury so called I'm
dealing and what we wanted to do
actually is to see how does it perform
compared to two-dimensional primary and
pata site cultures and what you can see
here is a graph actually of in the
x-axis a large variety of known compound
so-called drug-induced liver injury
compounds and you see the circles are
actually the 2d and primary hepatocyte
cultures and the fills dots are the
human liver micro tissue data so it's
always the ic50 value that is
highlighted here but what you can see is
a doll is very interesting is that if
you use a 3d culture you for a large
variety of so-called induced
drug-induced liver in compounds you see
that you have a sensitivity which is
much higher than if you just would use a
2d culture so the circles dots on the
top that are still and not not detected
- which are on the upper of the of the
graph show that with the 2d culture the
ic50 value is not detectable whereas
using 3d culture it is detectable so we
have a much greater sensitivity using a
3d human liver market issue compared
with standard culture this is just a
summary table of a couple of compounds
that actually were not able to be
detected as really positive but it's
highlighted in red where it is actually
positive and you could actually text
them using the 3d model an important
fact is actually also if you compare
here in to these graphs are also on the
left side 2d
right side em the 3d is actually that
you are even able to discriminate
between compounds that are basically
addressing the same function so you can
highlight for example of until receptor
antagonist and the primary impact aside
in 2d you're not able to at all detect
these toxic compounds whereas the human
liver micro tissues you're able to
discriminate and different daily
compounds even though they are I'm
addressing and the same mechanistic and
toxicity an important just an important
aspect is actually down now we have
which were just addressing a healthy and
micro tissue model but we can push these
3d tissue micro tissues also into
disease model as for example a liver
fibrosis model so what we do here is we
use this just validated and 3d micro
tissue and we add selected human stem
cells and with the more complex model
which is now not just the core culture
there's a triple or even quadruple
culture we are able now to reflect some
or some of the fibrotic and mechanisms
that are happening happening also kind
of in fibrosis and this is basically the
pipeline and so we use what you can do
with this model is and you can on the
one hand stimulates the disease so we
have the quadruple culture and using
specific stimuli such as a fibrosis and
using compounds or tgf-beta
and you can create the fibrosis model
that you can see here in center using
this equitable culture and from that
point of view and you can also inhibit
the disease using an antibiotic marker
and inhibit actually the progression of
fibrosis and you can use the 3d micro
tissue model and going into a lot of
throughput compatible
points on the right side which are about
chemical assay gene expression its
ecology and and and high content
analysis so here are a couple of graphs
actually that shows that you are able
and to in use and the fibrotic disease
state by for example I'm an activated
stellate marker and that is increasing
or the inner Nile are increasing by
increasing and actually stimuli of
tgf-beta and over several days so we can
see here that as stay seven and this Pro
and this activated stellar market is
highly expressed at high concentration
of tgf-beta the same for collagen and
type one marker and that is actually
produced by the activated state cells
that are in the Attic culture also here
we have those response due to the
increase of the concentration of
tgf-beta further we also see that of all
the fiber-optic markers at page 7 of
treatment so standard activity and
fibrosis activity and also different
extracellular cellular matrix protein
I'm going pretty quickly over and these
these different these different markers
actually the main message here should be
that we cannot only produce a 3d cell a
healthy 3d liver micro tissue structure
but we can also drive them into
different disease model which opens the
spectrum of analyzing healthy or
diseased liver tissues here are just a
couple of pictures actually that show
histological sections actually of turn
of them aprotic and tissues where a
seeded RP staining on the left side of a
control nearly no collagen expression
and whereas if we stimulate this with
tgf-beta you see a large collagen
expression inside the micro tissue
distributed quiet homogeneously through
the whole and whole micro tissue
another model that I want to quickly
emphasize here or so-called is the
pancreatic model that we have a 3d islet
Micro tissues and the islets the island
of Langerhans are actually inside and
the pancreas of the human body and look
like this and was a different sizes so
here you see at one of these islets that
are incorporated actually in the
pancreas and they include a lot of
different cells so beta cells alpha
cells Delta cells that are visualized
here and different colors and these
different cell types are interacting
highly with each other and creates the
response that we actually experience in
the human body if you're for example
eating and you have a higher eCos
concentration or the glucose
concentration is increasing in your
human body and as a result you then have
the secretion of insulin by for example
the beta cells so an important fact here
is that this communication between the
different cell x is only working in 3d
as you can see here in the graph so
insulin secretion is highly stimulated
in the 3d version whereas if you would
culture these micro-p these cells in a
2d layer they cannot properly
communicate with each other and you
don't have the response that you would
actually expect so i'll my three tissues
or islands only function in 3d there is
no 2e alternative and the problem is if
you look at primary eyelids and for in
vitro testing you have some limitations
one of them is you have a large
variation inside as you can see here in
this section through through the
pancreas so they have different sizes
are very heterogeneous you some have
complete different a ratio of cells that
are incorporated yeah also the rival
purity and you have cell types that are
actually not contributing to the
response of the islets which makes it
very difficult to be used as a tool for
drug discovery because it needs to pick
them so that you have a certain amount
of and comparable study and finally you
have a very short viability in culture
just around three to four days which is
reducing actually your window of
experimental window so what we optimized
here is actually what we are doing is we
use are we taking the human pancreas we
isolate the human islets we dissociates
them into single cell suspension and
then we recreate or rearrange them into
so-called human Island micro tissues
that have a cultured in a 96-well plate
and can MB be addressed or handled using
standard pipetting tools in a very
reproducible and reliable way an
important fact is that if we react or
gate is human iron micro tissues they
have the same composition as in the
human eyes so the left side here you see
actually and the composition after
aggregation on the right side as
comparison as empty our M observed the
human body what you can see is human
islets actually that they have an
increased response due to increase
insulin secretion due to increased
glucose equation and this is also what
you can and what you can see here in the
graph at the same is actually happening
in our micro issues so with increasing
concentration of glucose we have an
increased secretion of insulin so a very
and physiological response the insulin
content in the micro tissues is constant
and over this time and also empty ATP is
very common most important is that this
function is maintained or at least 28
days so we're experimental window is
increasing substantially compared to
native islets so the islets I stay
constant ATP contents taste constants
and on the bottom most important your
response to glucose is the same
independent of the day of culture so at
a 70
are they ready you still have the same
response to raise up so these are a
couple of two examples of Micro tissues
that we are able to produce in a highly
reproducible wave on 96 or 384-well
platforms and for for screening
applications so the 3d my own tissue has
a large advantage so you have a
technology or I just showed that you
have a technology that allows you to
produce a lot of different organ models
using the same manufacturing technology
and in our hands we currently have brain
Micro tissues liver mica tissues
pancreatic micro tissues that are just
presented you tumor micro tissues or
skin micro tissues are available and
also the heart further we can advance
them into different I mean different
disease models of fibrosis their toes is
there are also different species that
are available so human monkey dog grab
for the liver market issues and we can
also increase in complexity so for tumor
micro tissues going from cell lines or
PBMC in activations of home cultures and
two primary derived say no grass that I
click on directly from the patient's so
these micro tissues as I said are
produced me reproducibly on demand in a
scalable format and here for example a
picture of a 384 well plate 384
identical micro tissues and they're
basically placed inside the box and
share it directly to the customer so
this is this is the basic actually for
the multi Kishu systems that i would
like to present you now so multi tissue
systems have one one of the major goals
of multi tissue systems is actually
trying to imagine emulate systemic
interaction of compounds in the human
body if you just look at a single cell
type or one micro tissue in a well you
actually are addressing an isolated
pathway let's say and if you want to
look at the interaction between
different organs these interactions
ought to become available in the animal
so the goal of this multi TV experiment
is actually to look at interactions on
already the individual format in the
preclinical testing so here is just a
very romantic view so you have a couple
of compartments in which you have the
culture of acidic organ model they are
interconnected in a physiological way
and there is media recirculated between
the different organ models yeah I mean
you have some infusion parts that allow
you to address that include some some
compound sampling ports for analysis a
pump that circulates the medium in
between and the different the different
models so we can actually now
incorporate directly our micro tissues
inside as such a model because we have
them already available and this allows
us basically and to create such kind of
a multi tissue system and what we need
now is and we need a microfluidic system
or a circular circular e system that
allows us to inter correct
interconnects these different organ
models and to create such kind of a
multi multi tissue tissue system this is
actually marrying two different
technologies on the one hand it's 3d
culture so a physiological cell model on
the left side and microfluidic
technology on the right side and both of
these technologies have a lot of
different variations and it is basically
key to have on one hand the 3d
technology that is fully functional in a
microfluidic technology and on the other
hand having the micro technology
engineered in a way that is fully
compatible with CD cell cultures and
maintains the viability functionality
over time when they are interconnected
and with each other another important
aspect here is its timing and what I
mean was timing is if you create well
it's a 3d cell culture models are
already pretty complex by themselves so
they need to be created
need to mature and need to be cultured
in a way that is a functional overtime
so now you want to connect them with
each other in a microfluidic system that
itself can be complicated using
different pumps abusing disaster that's
all and so on but what you also need to
address is actually the kind of the
supply chain management you need to
ensure that when you connect different
micro tissues with each other you
creates the multi tissue system but all
of these single components is actually
available on demand and at the same time
is functional and viable and when you
start the experiment so different Milan
tissues can have different maturation
time they need to be cultured in
different medium they need to be
produced in different medium and then
you need to type that in a way that they
zero they're actually functional you can
transfer them into the system or they
are ready to use and then you can start
your boutique experiment and this is
something what we addressed was the
following approach so we are using our
already reliable and standardized of
chase micro tissue production that is
done using the hang drop method and and
we are able using the technology of
micro issues to do that on demand and in
a QC manner so we can first QC the micro
tissues so that's ensure the
functionality and then we are
transferring them into a micro fluidic
system where they're cultured inside a
microfluidic Channel and that they are
interconnected with each other and
they're the experience much higher evil
eye conditions so higher certain liquid
ratios there is better liquid turnover
by the convection through flow and
they're experiencing dynamic mechanical
forces and that we actually did for that
it's something that I want to present
now in a little bit more detail so it's
a polystyrene chip and that you can see
here on the top which is actually part
of a frame where it is integrated and
where the different compartments are
actually within the
yes standard plate format so this is a
system that is fully compatible with
automation and having a little bit
closer look at it and looking at the
cross section has two channels so there
are two channels on each chip at one
channel cross section locks them as you
can see it here and on the left the
right side has a liquid reservoir and in
between there is a small microfluidic
channel that is into connecting 10 micro
Taoiseach compartments these micro tesha
compartments and can talk with each
other the magnetism compartment is
engineering for the magnet issues which
means that it is made that micro tissues
can be cultured optimally in they can be
loaded and removed in a very simple way
you can see here the micro teacher
compartment it has such kind of a
funnel-like structure and has a rim on
the top and the micro tissue just holds
around 1 micro litre of volume and is
top open so we call that so-called
standing drop or so we leave that
standing drama port actually open over
the duration of the whole experiment
this allows us having a minimum dead
volume of additional features one of
them is we have optical access from the
top and off the bottom so lights can
easily penetrate and we can ever hope to
get access using an inverted microscope
further we have a direct local oxygen
supply through the liquid air interface
at the vicinity of the of the macro
tissue which some extent can be
sometimes for problematic if you don't
have a permeable and macro future
further it allows us to do a so-called
contacts transfer so the micro tissue is
M can be addressed from the top directly
for loading the micro tissue in the
compartment and to remove the micro
tissue of the experiment and for
downstream analysis and finally in the
liquid air interface is basically a
dynamic
brain which allows us to go up and down
and create an integrated pump so that
medium can be exchanged efficiently in
that small dead volume that this
compartment is creating so what we
actually did was that microfluidic chip
which is we simplified from the circular
II system that you can see that I
presented at the beginning very
schematically into a linear version so
we now have different market issues that
can be aligned in a line and one of the
most important and features out of it is
due to miniaturized W we can now
paralyze these micro tissue systems or
micro tissue experiments in a very
reproducible way so the flow is actually
generated using tilting of the strips so
we have reservoir on each side of this
magnitude of the of this chip and by
tilting and the microfluidic chip back
and forth we create a hydrostatic and
pressure between the upper reservoir and
the lower reservoir and this hydrostatic
pressure is generating its low from the
top reservoir to the low reservoir and
interconnects using flow the different
micro tissue compartments we don't need
any cubing for EM for this activation of
flow and the chip is basically our
system is kept as and as simple as
possible and for scaling we can just use
a multiple of these plates we can stack
them above each other onto such a
tilting platform that then is placed
directly inside and inside an incubator
so this technology now allows us a high
and a lot a lot of flexibility and who
is respect to preclinical applications
that we can arrange so it can actually
literally load whatever micro tissue
into one or multiple of these ten
compartment
inside this linear channel so and this
allows us to do a lot of different
combinations and a lot of different and
preclinical multi tissue and
configurations and applications but one
important step now is to incorporate the
Micro tissues inside and into every to
detail so due to the fact that our
concepts relies on this transfer we need
to ensure that this transfer is done in
a reproducible and highly efficient way
and this is actually what we engineered
here so what you can see here for
example is on the left side you see a
couple of production plates of liver and
tumor micro tissues and we can use now
is an automated setup where we can pick
up the market issues with a pipette or a
multi-channel pipette
directly out of the production plate we
run over to the microfluidic and place
we do a contact transfer and the micro
tissue is directly and included into the
into the mind of the compartment in a
parallel and very automated way and what
you will see now and on the next slide
is actually a small video which shows
this using and janati and 90 channel i'm
wellhead and allow us to do the prowler
transfer from the traffic plate and into
the microfluidic chip
you
so what you have seen is that the micro
tissues have been picked up 20 in
parallel you could nicely see how the
micro tissue is sedimenting insides to
chip inside and the tip towards the
bottom of the liquid-air interface and
then you just need a small contact with
the microfluidic compartment and the
micro tissue is directly transferred in
to the compartment and then can be used
for imaging for for cultivation and we
can even push that toward full
automation which means that it can't let
an automated robot to do the loading and
what you can actually see in the next is
an automated taking place assembly so we
have two production plates and one is
either micro tissue and one is liver
micro tissue and a robotic transfer that
fills out a complete and microfluidic
chip within five minutes
you
so once the micro played the mikrotik
played is loaded it is sealed using foil
and then goes on top of this tilter and
inside the incubator and from this time
point on can be handled as a standard
micro plate you can remove it for
analysis optical analysis you can
exchange the medium you can remove
samples for downstream analysis and at
the end of the experiment you can you
can remove the micro tissues and do
analysis on the micro tissues themselves
so what we now I want to quickly go into
it is a couple of different applications
that we are currently working on and one
of them is we load accurate Egypt only
with labor market issues which allows us
to address the NPK questions and
increase the cell to liquid ratio I
would like to go into in applications on
the ecology side and where we combine
tumor and liver micro tissues and first
first a result studied it's in the
metabolic disease range where we combine
actually pancreatic islets with liver
micro tissues inside a micropedic chips
further applications are in the
direction of metabolic competence if you
look at toxicity of compounds that first
need to be metabolized or have side
effects you to metabolization on the
heart and on the skin and there you can
easily combine liver micro tissues with
art or skin micro tissues so one of the
first application is actually the NPK
so one of the important questions in the
implicate apartment is the clearance of
compounds which means that every
compound has pharmacokinetic and
concentration curve that you see
actually here on the right side so a
compound is increasing in concentration
after uptake goes to the therapeutic
range over a certain time and then it
decreases some concentration decreases
in the human body down to zero again and
this decrease is the so-called clearance
of the human body and
clearance is a very important parameter
to define dosage of a compound at the
concentrations that can be taken and
this clearance is actually done extra is
investigated in vitro but just but just
incubating the compound together with an
Patek model which can be primary a pata
side suspension plated cells and what
you look at is the concentration of the
parent compound that is depleting over
time this gives you an idea on how the
clearance will be in the human body the
problem here is now that currently
pharmaceutical companies are tending
towards compounds that are much more
stable which means that there's there
the clearance is very low and they are
much more stable in the human body which
means that you can do less dosage one
pill per week etc the problem is now if
you use these in vitro models with these
compounds and you have impact side
cultures that are very short-lived in
this limited amount of time you're not
able to see any clearance which makes it
very difficult to predict the clearance
occurring the human body and the idea
here is actually to use the micro
tissues which are much more
physiological and have model much more
time stable and what we have is much
higher cell to liquid ratio and Pacific
tivity is much higher and a further we
can actually improve the selectivity or
the metabolizing capacity of this micro
cashews in the micro fluidic system as
you can see on the right curve and where
we see that the sip activity which is
which is actually the reason of the
clearance of specific compounds it's
much higher if you culture it in a
microfluidic environment compared to the
static so we can actually combine the 3d
culture increasing the cell to liquid
ratio and even increasing the metabolic
function of the liver and micro tissues
so that you are able to better clear or
to better predict such kind of low
clearance compounds
and this is something what it can see
you so these are three compounds
quinidine totem items buffering which
are very low clearance compounds that
usually have very difficulties to be
predicted in vitro assays and what you
can see here this first result showed
using the system so having multiple
market issues in a very small volume we
are able to actually see a clearance
down to 37 23 and 30% it was these
values now you have actually the
capability to predict the clearance of
these compounds and in vivo and other
applications that I want to go into is
the so-called hepatic prodrug activation
so here it's part of an oncology
applications where we are combining two
micro tissues with liver micro tissues
the reason why we are doing that exactly
that they are so-called programs as for
example cyclophosphamide that first
needs to be metabolized by the liver
before they are actually active in the
human body and are able to attack razeq
have an effect on a specific cancer so
signal fall so mine is actually
transformed before hydroxy Health for
some ID which is spontaneous a transfer
into other for some ID and which then
has an effect a cancer and it is
something that we actually could
reproduce in the micro fluidic system
but only first is we actually tested
what is the effect of cyclophosphamide
directly on the tumor and what you can
see here on the two graphs is on the
left side is where we looked at it
static so we just had two more micro
tissue in a well plate and we looked at
the growth of the micro tissue in the
presence of the options or
cyclophosphamide where you can actually
see that there is not a lot of
difference and also in the micro fluidic
system where we had three different
concentrations zero zero point 1 and 1
milli molar of cyclophosphamide and
where you can see on the right side very
significantly the growth of the micro
kitchen two more
and from day zero to and they age so in
all of these and concentrations it was
unhindered growth of the tumor micro
tissue so what we then did is we are
it's the liver which is actually
metabolizing cyclophosphamide and
interestingly when we did it in the
static version where we first pre
incubated the cyclophosphamide and here
on the left side together and with the
liver and then transfer it to be tumor
we did not see any effects even though
we had quite a high concentration of
cyclophosphamide but if we did a direct
connection between the liver microti
issue and - micro tissue inside the flow
system we actually could see at 1 milli
molar of concentration the tumor seized
to grow so there is a cytostatic effect
if we culture or co-culture liver and
tumor in the presence of 1 millimolar of
cyclophosphamide which is also very
visible on the pictures on the right
side where you can see that the very
right bottom image a much smaller micro
tissue a much less grow of after to
reputation this indicates basically that
for very unstable metabolites as for
example for hydroxy cycle for smile it
is important to co-culture the two
different and tissue models side by side
and we could also actually measure the
different metabolites so what you can
see here with all the tumor you can only
see the parent compound on the left side
I'm using mass spectroscopy but if you
actually have the liver in the system we
see the appearance of the different
metabolites that have been measured
using M mass spectroscopy analysis
another quick experiment that we did and
compound inactivation for example there
is a finale which is actually a
travertine is also a so-called and drunk
the first M needs to be metabolized by
liver into fexofenadine which
has then an antihistamine component and
importantly careful Nadine has been
removed from the market because itself
has a toxic effect on heart and so liver
is actually detoxifying personally this
is something what we wanted to test and
we did this in actually energy and that
we constructed prior to the ones I've
just presented but just as proof of
concept we can see here on the top
different graphs so if you don't have
any little micro tissue inside the
system and just the heart my petitions
you see the beating is stopping already
have to pay to in the presence of
personally but if you basically the
green dots action but if you have to
present what we see actually that the
beating is maintained so you still have
beating up day two and stay for which
means that 13 is very quickly
transformed into fix affinity which
itself then has much less toxic effect
on the heart if we use an inhibitor we
again see the cytotoxic effect of
unfunctional effect of turf and Adeem on
the hearts on the very right and curve
here as well and then finally a couple
of insight into first cow cultures that
mediate and combining the islets micro
tissue and together with the labor
market issues so first of all what we
saw is that if we culture the island
micro tissue in a microfluidic
environment and the response and the
functionality is increased so here in
purple you actually see a standard
culture and so called glucose stimulated
insulin secretion assay and always two
bars so the small bar is a very low
glucose and the large bar is at high
glucose and the difference having a
large difference is a good indicator of
proper functionality of the micro tissue
its accretion rates having 2 5 or even
10 micro tissues inside the micro
fluidic compare
is nearly doubled on dependent of how
much micro tissues we have in the micro
fluidic system so we can culture up to
10 micro tissues in the same volume and
liquid volume without decreasing the
functionality of the single micro issues
further what we see if you look at
chronic insulin secretion is that it
chronic insulin secretion is much lower
which gives us an indication that the
islets are less stressed when they are
cultivated on the flow we also stayed
some first Co culturing experiment that
you can see here and we looked at two
ATP sorry for that we looked at at ATP
and we actually don't see a difference
and between if we call culture the micro
tissues with each other and as Amy would
have cultured them alone without the
other micro tissues interestingly on the
functional side is that if we culture
the liver micro tissues together with
the islet micro tissues is that the
albumin secretion which is a functional
marker for a liver is maintained at high
concentrations so this is something that
we are continuing now to investigate
especially over a longer period of time
important is also that we would like to
study the glucose homeostasis so how can
cause is regulated by these two tissues
you can also add a metabolic sync for
example fats or muscle micro tissues and
also advancing and the system into dvdc
state such as replacing the islands by
the beaches type 1 and type 2 the island
models are also exchanging the little
micro tissues by an aesthetic a liver
and which and which has a much higher
amounts of fat inside so these are a
couple of applications that are just
wanted to highlight and which gives you
actually an insight on the flexibility
and possibility of that micro fluidic
system so it is very versatile and
allows you to combine I combined a lot
of different micro tissues inside the
same system for a large
variety of preclinical efficacy and
toxicity testing applications and at the
same time the system the flow is
actually improving tissue specific
in-vitro functionality and does this not
only in a very robust and a simple
manner allows you to scale it so due to
the simplicity of the flow of the
microfluidic set up it allows you to M
to experiment a lot of different
applications and a lot of different
replicates in parallel and therefore can
be truly scaled for in a reliable and
robust manner with this slide I want to
end and at the end I want to acknowledge
the different people that were involved
in developments over the last couple of
years this is a ETH with my engineering
laboratory and Roche and also ETH at the
SEC basically then collaborators at at
ETH there are a couple of funding
agencies that work and providing money
so that these projects could be could be
developed I would also like to thank all
of you for your attention and if there
are questions I'm happy to answer them
thank you dr. Frey for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar so if you
have a question you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your question into the box it
appears on your screen and click on the
send button well answer as many of your
questions as we have time for so let's
get started our first question is what
is the liquid volume in the micro
fluidic system the system is laid out in
a way to confirm fifty two hundred
microliters of liquid in the medium
with one up to 10 micro tissue so you
can vary the cell to the equal to issue
in an aquatic civil way okay or next one
is what is his medium available for
micro tissue in the system so the medium
is then I mean the medium is then
basically depending on all the different
the ratio so if you have for example 10
micro tissues in a hundred micro tissue
of volume you basically have just a 10
micro liter per micro tissue but due to
the fact that there is flow all 10 micro
tissues are crazy the handle microliter
so there is a much more efficient medium
exchange inside inside the micropedic
system the compartment itself just has a
1 micro litre volume but you to flow
this one microliter it is continuously
exchanged thank you next one is
different organ models need different
medium composition how do you account
for that in multi this is a very
important question so especially for the
production the micro tissues might be
very sensitive to what are the medium
compositions but this is actually the
reason why we completely decouples the
production and from the production from
from the culturing so the different
micro tissues can actually be produced
in their native medium and then can be I
commit I limited to a certain common
medium so the common medium is then a
very important aspect and will defer
from applications and what American
tissues are combine with each other so
every combination might need an
optimization of the medium and the
medium needs to have the compare needs
to have components which are compatible
with an application so for example for a
clearance applications that I just saw
before we want to have a medium that has
a low protein content because compounds
might assorted proteins so this is
also engineering aspect aspects that
comes along with setting up an
engineering multi tissue systems but due
to the fact that we have a parallel
system we can test a lot of different
media compositions so that we can
optimize the different mediums towards
the final application thank you how can
you simulate circular flow so yes this
is a question that comes up often we as
you can see we actually simplified the
system in a way that we don't have a
perfect circulation our circulation is
basically going from bi-directional so
it goes from one reservoir to the other
reservoir but a simplification of the
organ model itself which is the micro
tissue makes this simplification very
reasonable because a circulating flow
only makes sense actually if a component
is substantially transformed when it
passes one time through an organ model
and this is due to two simplification of
the system anyways not the case so we're
not able to reproduce a one passage
through the model that we have it here
so the simplification of having a
bi-directional flow and is not that much
of an issue in our system however you to
divide the National flow we have to some
extent circulation in a way that we can
simulate our concentration so the same
medium is cultured with the maggot
issues or the defined number of time
which allows you actually to have enough
concentration for example of metabolized
toxic compound and so on well I would
like to once again thank dr. Frey for
his presentation I would also like to
thank lab roots for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through August 31st
2018
you will receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be a
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event that
is all for now thank you for joining us
we hope to see you again soon
goodbye